haven smith bats ninth and plays right
field
the d backs first round pick in the 2017
draft out of the university of virginia
the seventh overall selection in that
draft
carson kelly wants it down
and zach allen's got strikeout number
one
and that'll bring up designated hitter
ty france france with the home run last
night and i'm telling you he belted one
way out to left center field last night
oh he got this one got a breaking ball
and just absolutely obliterated it one
nothing mariners
ty france back to back ball games now
with home runs at his second as a
mariner rbi number six
allen's got strikeout number two
so seeger draws a walk that'll bring up
left fielder jose marmaleos
it's one heart that's a gap shot
see how fast seeger can run he's gonna
get the third
and here he comes digging for a home
here's the throw to the plate he is in
there
two-nothing mariners mariners now have
runners on it first and second with two
out
that's it hard down the line fair ball
marmalaos will walk home evan white to
long strider let's see if they send him
and indeed he does he scores couple of
runs on that one luis terrence on the
board with his first two marine rbis and
the boys have a four nothing lead
got him three strikeouts in the inning
but seattle gets four standard justice
sheffield has been staked to an early
4-0 lead by his offense
as we head to the bottom of the first
inning i've seen it here in the first
that two-seam fastball a big key for him
look at that right on the corner
three fastballs in a quick strikeout
took a little off of that
nice operation for an easy turn
3-2 to seeger
walked in five-nothing mariners rbi for
siegers 33rd
fourth walk
[Applause]
in the air left field peralta's got to
run ahmed's out there and nick has got
it over the shoulder and hustles it back
into the infield
and everybody has to stay put how did he
get there and make the catch
kind of took a peek and realized david
peralta was not going to get there well
they're loaded with nobody out for david
peralta who has been excelling in these
situations
[Applause]
long run here marmo is there
and a runner will hold
here's wyatt matheson
base hit
i'm at his home here comes walker the
throw for marmalejos is
not in time
wyatt mathis in a two-run single gets
the diamondbacks on the board as we go
to the top of the fifth today baron is
five and now the diamondbacks two here's
the pitch swing and a well-hit ball deep
to right field this one is way back
going and going and goodbye baseball
jose marmaleos with his fifth home run
of the season
on two run drive way out of here to
right field in the top of the fifth and
it's now the mariners seven
and the diamondbacks two and for the
mariners their second home run of the
night wow what a shot by jose
followed by mathison and van meter five
six and seven in the order
down he goes
strikeout number five for justice
sheffield
[Applause]
strike three called six strikeouts for
chef two down here in the sixth see what
he goes to here twists deals
swing and a miss a helpless cut by van
meter a vicious slider in the dirt down
he goes and sheffield strikes out the
side
escobar with a grin at the third single
the center fly to right
[Applause]
bobbled
good recovery dylan moore
there's been a five-game hitting streak
on the line here
another one four more this will get a
walker home and it's seven to three
[Applause]
hit center field
kyle lewis has got it
on one
on the ground backhanded nicely by
seeger right to it one out
[Applause]
kelly swings to the breaking ball takes
it deep to right right to left field big
partner marmos right there two out
down the third this will do it seeger in
time game over baron has won it 7-3 and
congratulations to justice sheffield his
first
big league road win